avec la libye claveau fait votre vie oui
alors vous vous occupez de mascara très
bien c'est parti pascal vous êtes très
très amoureux de votre femme catherine
êtes toujours un sens oui si l'on met
dernier enseignement c'est le cas vous
dites bâle une belle intelligente
sensible c'est vrai mais la poutre donc
c'est exact c'est vrai ça savons c'est
une femme bon déclaré sur twitter n'est
alors je lève
nous sommes en fait j'avais dit ça
j'avais écrit ça au lendemain de ce
cabinet moi qui parlais des femmes qui
avaient un certain âge et ce jour là
voilà j'avais effectivement vu très
amoureux du coup j'ai décidé de vous
faire une interview par amour on adore
est-ce que par amour pour catherine vous
accepteriez de vivre à 3 ah ça dépend
qui est le troisième a dénoncé le
troisième n'est pas fermée hommes femmes
habile et plutôt vers l'asie je ne
savais pas qui est le troisième c'est
l'horreur est-ce que par amour pour
catherine vous accepteriez une
plénoplastie une fée de crin c'est pas
penalty alors une peine aux plastiques
basset s'est clairement traduite pas
bien mais je vous ai dit j'accepte tout
amour c'est la base vos photos faut
toujours tout accepté pas très bien mais
je suis impressionné
est-ce que par amour pour catherine vous
accepteriez de sortir en club échangiste
cycling team est celle qui accepteraient
pas non mais là je demande bien sûr à
écouter ce que oui je séchais le
problème des clubs échangistes c'est
parce qu'on a rien à échanger
je fais non c'est pas assez
ben c'est pas là que j'irai en premier
en tout cas mais s'il vous me demandez à
6m elle demandait jamais avec fabien
lecoeuvre plus fabien lecoeuvre
comme il est petit peu demi tarif par
amour parce que vous resteriez au sexe
au sexe
non non pourquoi il croise les doigts si
elle vous le demandez toujours pareil
catherine elle ne me le demande pas réa
bleu nuit du destin écoutez en tout cas
je pensais pas qu'on allait chuter
[Musique]
en fait j me dire quelque chose assez
amusant d'être avec vous parce que je
vois laurent lamy également cyril et
paulos vous êtes des vous êtes des
artistes est parfois bon en fait nous on
est assez timide
les jaunes c'est vrai je trouve que au
rhône et on n'est pas du tout dans la
même
en fait on est mal choisi mais ça voilà
on est un peu moi oui oui le retour de
l'animal c'est par amour
si t'arrives toi est-ce que par amour
qui accepteraient de vivre à trois
sièges c'est qui la troisième personne
quand même juste pour que préparation ce
serait qu'il puisse être est ce qui se
fait sur un des super bowl
l'auteur de repreneur est-ce que par
amour six athlètes d'aller en club
échangiste sial salon
non alors franchement non serena j'aime
pas du tout moi je suis très jaloux je
bisous est ce que vous êtes célibataire
série le dépêchez vous j'ai envie d'y
être